if what I really want is the derivative
of the original function which is
devided DX do you see I can combine
these two to get the dy and the DX
pieces that I need what dy on DX is a
fraction is it not dy on D you
multiplied by D or DX right
it's a bit weird because we're
considering D or D X both as an operator
and then D or D X of stuff as a fraction
that we can move around but it's true dy
is a little change in Y do you is a
little change in U and D extra little
change in X and if it's the same little
change then just like anything else in
fractions you can cancel them these are
going to cancel and leave you with the
derivative that you actually want so I'm
just going to write what I know these
things should be do you why do you risk
3u squared
what's the or DX it's just one now being
that I'm now working out do y on DX I
don't need to talk about this
substitution that I introduced before
right so I can just say dy on DX and get
rid of all of the use replace it with
the substitution I started with which I
think you'll find if you expand because
X plus 2 squared is 1 x squared plus 4x
plus 4 right then you multiply by 3 and
sure enough this is what you get
when you say just treat it as a normal
thing you have to expand to do that
successfully right if for example and
I'm going to get into libera they picked
a really simple one right if I put
something messy in here let's just try
this actually let me write this off on
the side if I said differentiate this
instead x squared minus four will do and
let's still do the power of three okay
mate I hope this is getting of what
you're asking how come I can't just
bring this power out the front and then
reduce it by one how come I can't just
save this like that and the answer is
because you'll get the wrong answer if
you go ahead and you do the expansion
right you'll get you four terms you'll
see what happens with the powers and
then you'll get an answer at the end if
on the other hand you try this and you
expand it you will not get the same
thing it just doesn't work right and so
why are we considering it like this well
because some of the rules that we've
applied like just thinking about this as
a normal object don't work in this new
calculus world that we're exploring and
so that's why we introduce better tools
that will do this so why is it called
chain rule why is it called chain rule
chain rule is so named because of this
step here there is as it were a chain of
derivatives that have been sort of stuck
together and if you chain them along in
the correct way to get things cancelling
then you get the derivative that you
want so this chain of derivatives gets
you to this result which is much quicker
than having to expand I don't have to
write all this out like eventually
what's a more comfortable with this kind
of do a lot of this in my head but this
is what's happening behind the scenes
it's also called it's a bit more awkward
but it's more descriptive name in
addition to chain rule this is worth
writing down it's called the function of
a function rule do you remember I
introduced you it-- reduced a new
function right and that function is
having a
the function applied to it that makes it
a function of a function but it doesn't
quite roll off the tongue the same way
as chain rule so your cubicle the first
and not the second okay